do you think you're inspiring younger
guys to want to become gangsters or what
part of your message is to say do not
choose to live my life
because you don't even know it yourself
that last 20 minutes
if a 20 year old kid listens to that
that message may be like well i want to
be that guy because i want to be i want
people to be proud of me to get if a guy
like that got you know sammy to get
emotional on a podcast where he said i
don't want to talk about it anymore i
want to get that kind of respect in my
life can you please unpack that so young
person listening to this is not going to
get stuck on the fact that i want to be
that person one day i said it 100 times
you want to be me
god
i got 22 years in prisons i kill people
friends
i've seen death over and over again
there's no win from being a gangster
freedom is the most important thing you
can be
don't take me as a i'll take him
look at patrick when he's doing
a lot of things
a lot of money wealthy good life
just had a baby
i lost all that
this isn't something to recruit
this is something to understand what
you'll be
you're killing your best friend
on orders
and you'll do it or you'll die
you may not live to 40.
and if you do probably a good hunk of
that will be in prisons
they'll tell you when to when to
eat when to go to sleep when to get up
if that's what you want
but there's life out here
like i'm doing now you want to be me
i'm making money
doing
legitimate things
and it's not just because it's my
story it's i could do it anybody's
thought
um
there's there's a bunch of different
ways in life
you don't have to go to college
there's money being a carpet a
plumber electrician
in trades you know college
they make a lot of money
up your boat they tell you your
sink call a plumber see what happens
guy comes in for 15 20 minutes a half
hour and you went for 200.
trade schools trade schools become
become something else because learn how
to edit out of this there's an industry
out here
doing this
there's people sitting around us all
over the place
they make a living
they don't go to prison they go home
their wife their kids their mothers
their fathers do it
i mean
this is not to be crude
this is to make you understand
johnny keys in that you could have been
johnny keys
i could have been johnny keys
there's no recruiting i mean if you want
to be if i can't stop people from being
crooks or gangsters or anything else
but
my life is a perfect life look at it
i don't know why i'm here he is god
sometimes i believe in god too i ask god
i was shot twice stabbed once
is there a special is there a thing you
need or want from me
that you want me to do
how do i survive these things it
wasn't easy
wasn't easy on my wife or my kids so if
you think this is a good role for you
you go do it but i'm telling you
you're not going to wind up in a good
way
so
but i'm not going to you know i don't go
telling kids what to do and what not to
do do whatever you want to do
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]